What we're doing now is we're storing, we have a cookie that
looks something like this. And on the service side when we receive this
cookie we make sure hashing one gives us this has value, and if
it doesn't we throw it away. Now, does this really solve our problem?
A little bit, but if they, you know, if this, if they
know we're using MD5, which is, you know, pretty easy to guess, it's
easy to forge a cookie, right? You can just, change the cookie value
to whatever you want, run MD5 on it, append that, and now you've
forged the cookie. So, how do we solve this problem?
Let me show you. What we need to do, is
we need to add, we need to have some secret
knowledge here. So instead of hashing, you know, the number
one into our hash, what we want to do is we
want to hash a secret string plus the number one into
a hash. So as long as this secret stays secret
a would be attacker even if they know our algorithm won't
be able to forge a hash. Because remember one of the
properties of a hashing algorithms is it's very difficult to find,
you know, find two inputs that equal the same hash. Or
to find a specific input for a specific hash and, and
vice versa. So, you know, they'll see in our cookie, you
know, they'll still see a cookie you know, the browser will
still see a cookie that looks like this, but instead of
hashing this one we added an extra little secret. And as long
as the attacker doesn't know the secret they won't
be able to generate the same hash. So let's build
the this functionality in bit by bit. There's one,
one last thing in Python I want to introduce you
to. So we've been using hashlib to run basic
hashes. There's a second library, specifically for doing message authentication
called HMAC, hash-based message authentication code. This is basically a,
a special algorithm. It's built in the Python, for when
you want to combine a, a key with your value to
create a hash. There's a series of different types of attacks
where you, you know, if you just put your key plus
the value you can find a collision by just kind of
extending your value. And similarly, if you put your value
and then the key there's, there's other attacks you can do.
An HMAC is basically just an algorithm that you know, looks
something approximately, like this: hmac, a secret, a key, hashing function,
returns a hash. So it, it'll, it'll look just like
using hashlib, except it'll take an extra parameter for secret,
which it'll incorporate in a secure manner. Now, you could
just call, you know, use a hashlib function, with, you know,
secret plus value. And that it gets you pretty close.
And for our purposes, it'll actually probably work just fine.
But HMAC is, is the proper to thing to use
here. Again you can, you can learn more about HMAC you
know, on Wikipedia or something. There's a wealth of information of what the
algorithm actually is. But it's basically a special way of using a particular
hashing function with the secret key. I'll show you that real quick in
Python how we, how we use it. Okay, let's review some of the
things we've talked about. If we were to make a hash the way
we've been doing it, you know, we'd use hashlib. I'll create an MD5
of a string. And call Hex Digest on it and we get you
know, the hex output. We can use the HMAC library to accomplish something
sim-, similar but HMAC takes an extra parameter for a secret and combines it
securely. You know, we could say hmac.new and we give it a secret. Then give it
udacity. We say hexdigest. And, and we
get a, you know, we get a similar output
except this is more secure. Of course we could
have done something like this. Secret plus udacity. And
as long as secret stays the same, when we verify
you know, our algorithm will still work. But, hmac
is just basically a more secure way of accomplishing secret
plus udacity. Let's use this new hmac function and a
new secret key to improve our make secure value function.